Schon in der Schule lernt man, dass der Planet
Venus der nächste Nachbar der Erde sind.
Doch das ist wohl alles nur eine Sache der
Perspektive.
Denn jetzt argumentieren drei Astronomen,
dass nicht die Venus der Erde am nächsten
ist, sondern der Merkur.
Und nicht nur das: Der neuen Computersimulation
zufolge ist Merkur außerdem auch allen anderen
Planeten des Sonnensystems am nächsten.
Wie genau das Forschungsteam auf dieses verblüffendes
Ergebnis kommt und wie wir Merkur als unseren
offensichtlich wahren Nachbarn so lange Zeit
übersehen konnten, erfahrt ihr jetzt bei
Clixoom Science & Fiction, herzlich willkommen!
Wenn man sich bisher darüber schlau macht,
wer der erdnächste Planet ist, wird man auf
die Venus kommen.
Auf ihrer Bahn um die Sonne kreist die Erde
zwischen den ellipsenförmigen Bahnen von
Venus und Mars.
Doch letzterer zirkuliert etwas weiter entfernt
von der Sonne als die Venus.
Diese kommt der Erde dabei am nächsten.
Und so wird die Venus mit einem Durchmesser
von rund 12.100 Kilometern als derjenige Planet
bezeichnet, der der Erde von allen Planeten
am nächsten kommt.
Der minimale Abstand beträgt laut der “European
Space Agency” (ESA) gelegentlich “nur”
40 Millionen Kilometern.
Beim Mars beträgt die Mindestentfernung demnach
56 Millionen Kilometer.
Doch das alles ist wohl reine Definitionssache.
Was also ist mit “Nähe” gemeint?
Der Planet, der der Erde ab und an am nächsten
kommt?
Nein, sagt jetzt ein Astronomie-Team in einem
aktuellen Aufsatz.
Stattdessen sei doch der mittlere Abstand
zur Erde entscheidend.
Anders ausgedrückt: Der Planet, der uns in
der meisten Zeit am nächsten ist.
Und schon hat die Erde einen neuen Nachbarn:
den Merkur nämlich.
Eine irre Vorstellung!
Schließlich gilt der Merkur als der kleinste
und innerste Planet unseres Sonnensystems.
Der Zwerg hat lediglich einen Durchmesser
von 4878 Kilometern, dabei allerdings eine
immense Masse von unvorstellbaren 330 Trillionen
Tonnen.
Merkur hat eine geringe Schwerkraft und seine
Oberfläche wird auf bis zu 430 Grad Celsius
aufgeheizt - hier würde sogar Blei schmelzen.
Doch nach den Berechnungen des Forschungsteams
befinden sich nicht nur die Venus, sondern
auch der Mars weiter von der Erde entfernt
als der Merkur - zumindest die meiste Zeit.
Demnach beträgt der durchschnittliche Abstand
der Venus zur Erde nämlich ganze 170 Millionen
Kilometer.
Gut 150 Millionen Kilometer dagegen ist der
durchschnittlicher Abstand des Merkur zu uns.
Denn auch wenn die Venus uns ab und an auf
etwa 40 Millionen Kilometer nahe kommt, befindet
sie sich den Großteil der Zeit auf der anderen
Seite der Sonne.
Und das Forschungsteam klärt in seinem aktuellen
Aufsatz noch mehr.
Mit Hilfe von Computer-Simulationen haben
die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
auch die tatsächlichen Positionen aller anderen
Planeten in den vergangenen 10.000 Jahren
analysiert.
Bei dieser Berechnung kam heraus, dass der
Merkur im Durchschnitt gesehen nicht nur der
Erde am nächsten ist.
Auch allen anderen Planeten des Sonnensystems
ist er der nächste!
Größenvergleich Sonnensystem.
Cooles Video.
Draufklicken. anschauen und Astro Comics TV
abonnieren!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!